hey there attack on titan fans how's the
new season treating you wait so you
never saw that coming
you were surprised by the insane amount
of character development the protagonist
has received well you're still wondering
about the morals and ethics of eren
yeager either way
as a tribute to the man who nearly
massacred half of libero
i'm bringing you 10 of the best erin
yeager moments in the series there won't
be any manga spoilers in this since i
need this video to be for everybody
also don't forget to subscribe for more
anime content like this and help us hit
the next milestone for this channel with
that said
bite your fingers here comes erin
yeager's best moments
at number 10 we have erin's rampage to
kill the female titan after witnessing
the death of the levi's squad
the theme of choice is something that
runs often in the narrative of attack on
titan you make the wrong choice
you pay the price and this time that
price is the death of the levi squad
when aaron arrived it was too late
but the boy did his best to avenge his
comrades this was the very first titan
shifter fight we saw in the series
and aaron yeager gave his best each of
his punches
was an echo of rage and can we take a
moment to appreciate his hatred-filled
declaration
to tear the female titan piece by piece
but if attack on titan has taught us one
lesson it's that anger doesn't solve
every problem this is quite nice because
normally when things go down
most anime characters switch their rage
mode on before smashing their opponents
but things don't work the same way with
annie because you're fighting with a
trained child soldier after all
error may have lost this fight but we're
adding it here because of his resolve to
avenge his comrades
and using his titan form with little
practice to scare the living hell out of
the female titan
next up we have aaron's resolve to kill
the female titan
motivation comes in various forms but in
attack on titan
motivation hits you when you spurt out
blood remember your mother's death
and echo your hatred for the titans so
things have gone down
badly and he's revealed to be the female
titan and she doesn't laugh and shrug it
off she actually laughs
and then transforms into a titan before
going on a killing spree
as for erin he's left there buried under
rocks and our screaming protagonist
loses his motivation for the first time
that's when mikasa comes and gives
the world is cruel motivational speech
aaron rises
gritting his teeth and boom you've got
one angry titan coming your way
and let's admit he made a damn good
entrance by literally punching annie in
the face
coming up next is the first fight
between aaron and reiner
in attack on titan friendships are the
easiest to make
and easiest to break and that line will
hit harder if you're a manga reader so
after the big reveals of rainer and
bertolt
aaron once again uses his rage mode to
pick a one-on-one duel with the armored
titan
so here we have a titan shifter trained
by the entire malian military plus
having years of control over his titan
versus a soldier
who barely knew the abilities of his
titan as expected
the first few moments don't go well but
an unlikely ally comes in the form of a
flashback
and for the first time in his life aaron
uses his brain
yes ladies and gentlemen it's a truly
praiseworthy moment with a combination
of martial arts
aaron overpowers reiner and our armored
titan soon learns the lesson of
underestimation
so hats off to aaron for using his brain
and making a massive leap
in terms of character development
well what do you know even though aaron
wasn't an expert in the brains
department back in the day he knows the
most badass way to do a power awakening
and to reject a love confession in the
second season we have another aaron gets
kidnapped arc
where the survey corps have to once
again sacrifice a number of soldiers
just to save him but this time
aaron doesn't walk away crying and
complaining when his mother's killer
appears right in front of him
and kills another person that mattered
in his life he's on the verge of giving
up but once again
mikasa to the rescue or mikasa to the
confession in this case
the red scarf she holds seems to have
more emotional weight than it shows
because aaron rising up once again
calls in the power of the founder okay
he literally doesn't call it and it
happened by coincidence but credit for
aaron for taking revenge on his mother's
killer and showing reiner and bertolt
the power of the coordinates
oh
at number six we have the second fight
between the female titan and eren so
continuing where i left off at number
nine we have aaron now running berserk
inside the city while chasing the female
titan
it seems he's now arrived at the
conclusion that annie should be killed
and there's no going back annie on the
other hand still thinks actively
predicting the attack titans moves and
attacking back nearly killing aaron with
three punches to the head
but here's where the magic happens
remember how i said rage doesn't solve
every problem
well it seems this time it does the new
berserk titan seems to take down annie
without any effort at all
and not in a pretty way if you never
knew about attack on titan and watch
this scene for the first time you'll
almost think annie's the innocent one
here
cheers to aaron for showing what his
true rage mode can achieve and let's
ignore him for bragging about destroying
the entire world right i mean he only
took down the female titan because of
his rage and got his ass kicked twice
how can this guy even think of
destroying the world
things changed a lot when the military
realized they have a titan on their side
but the hype soon died down when the
so-called titan punched his own face and
fell down unconscious
way to make a good first impression
aaron all jokes and idealistic symbols
aside this was one of the moments eren's
titan
actually helped the military to keep a
step forward in their fight against the
titans with the colossal titan once
again destroying the wall and the titans
swarming in the military was on the
verge of collapse
sure you've got levi flying around
killing a few titans here and there but
even he can't stop an army of titans at
once
in other words if aaron wasn't there
then humanity's war against titans would
have ended much sooner aaron wasn't in
his best form back then but due to his
actions
humanity secured their first victory
against the titans and peace was
restored
even though peace lasted only for a
couple of days it did matter a lot
[Music]
coming in next we have erin doing
something without using his titan form
for the first time
that's him taking down the colossal
titan okay
most of the credit here goes to armin
but the one who gave the final blow
matters as well
bertolt seemed to be the silent
introvert who always looked up to rainer
but when the spotlight shines on him he
doesn't forget to nuke a city and almost
burn one of the main characters alive
but armin's actions actually played to
eren's advantage
appearing from the back eren attacked
the nape of the titan and pulls the
titan shifter out it was a great
distraction but a great distraction
always comes with a much greater cost
this time the cost was arming and even
though it was a victory for aaron it was
a total loss for him as well he gained a
victory
but also learned a lesson and this
helped him keep another massive step in
terms of maturity
and character development
next up we have the second round of eren
and reiner's fight during the battle of
shigan china
in the first two seasons era might not
have been the smartest guy around but
after the events of the uprising arc he
relied more on his allies
and also thought a lot before doing the
punching this difference was clearly
visible during his second fight with
rainer
although the first fight involved a lot
of screams and curses this time
aaron actually predicted his opponent's
moves before using them against him he
also didn't use any bombastic dialogue
and rage quotes during this round of the
fight
and clearly you can see the advantages
of using one's brain during the fight
rhino was soon overpowered and the
armored titan was no longer the
strongest in the duel
aaron also relied on the power of his
friends with the thunderspears rather
than doing everything on his own and the
moral of the story is
if you use your head life's gonna be
much easier
coming in at number two is eren's
transformation during willie timer's
declaration of war we might have
predicted that aaron would use his brain
more in the upcoming arcs
but who in their wildest dreams thought
aaron could achieve an iq to combat like
yagami
if someone says you can't achieve
tension by putting two people in a room
and letting them talk then they're
clearly wrong
aaron establishes the setting for his
transformation perfectly he tells falco
to bring reiner threatens him with one
bleeding hand to show the consequences
of his transformation and waits
patiently until tiber declares war
so he can actually start counting the
victims anyone who watched this scene
wouldn't believe that this
is the boy who tried to solve everything
by screaming and punching
aaron's come a long way and he's
transformed from a boy filled with rage
to a cold calculating man needless to
say this was the scene where we realized
aaron is no longer the hero of the story
but the monster
the narrative created he was done with
pacifism and was moving forward with
bellicism i'll gladly place my bets and
confirm that your reaction when aaron
transformed
was similar to the reaction of the crowd
assembled
[Music]
and at number one the best moment of
eren jaeger so far
his fight with the warhammer titan well
words failed to explain this fight
should i start with how aaron provoked
the titan to transform or should i speak
about the climax of the fight
or even how brutal the attack titan
looked after the massacre
if aaron used 60 of his brain during the
second round with reiner then he clearly
went above and beyond in his levels of
iq during his fight with the warhammer
even when his head was chopped off and
his titan was on the verge of collapse
aaron's expression was still cold and
calculating as if he was thinking of a
way to take down the titan
rather than panicking and resorting to
rage each of his moves were well thought
out
and he was quick to figure out the
mystery behind the warhammer titan
the eren yeager you see now is way more
brutal and calculating
than the one you saw three seasons ago
and this ladies and gentlemen
is peak character development the eren
yeager you see
here is the man who would become one of
the greatest fictional characters
of all time
so there goes 10 of the best erin yeager
moments of all time
of course if you've caught up with the
manga you can probably think of several
other additions to this list but i
needed to keep this one manga spoiler
free
with that said i hope you enjoyed the
video and don't forget to drop a like if
you did that's it for today anime fans
and i'll see you in the next video